continuing to see trivialization  um of the holocaust at another one of  these anti-vaxx protests i believe this  one in new york city you see another one  of these yellow stars go by and i'll  play that again for our audience you can  see the yellow star kind of near the  penske truck  which says yellow it's a yellow star  that says unvaccinated on it the  continued trivialization of the  holocaust which  is uh just kind of standard operating  procedure at this point point for people  like marjorie taylor green and others so  every single weekend  every single weekend it is conspiracy  after conspiracy we had the sherry 10  penny video  of her saying that vaccinating children  is a late term abortion  and that covid testing is torture and on  and on and on and it is getting really  bad i don't know what turns this around  i really don't  uh but it is extraordinarily disturbing